[Music]
keeping a tradition alive for
generations is no piece of cake
but these timeless desserts have been
bringing delight for decades
even centuries with each one sweeter
than the last
these are ponchi or if it's on its own
it's a pond check
it's a polish treat made from
deep-frying dough with a stuffed sugary
jam
filling and then it's covered in even
more sugary icing
basically it's the definition of
delicious
wait don't touch we need to film it
first
warsaw's a vibrant city with a bit of a
sweet tooth
and that's where polsky comes in there
are a few spots around the city to get
palmski
but no more authentic than here this
tiny bakery has been producing panchky
since 1925.
[Music]
which is
sylvia's great-grandfather created the
secret family recipe which still stays
strong to this day
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and on fat thursday the last thursday
before lent
boy do they sell a few more does that
vertically
audition eight to ten thousand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guatemala is known for a lot of things
coffee
avocados but more than anything else it
should be known for chocolate
this is a place called chocola it's
known for rain
and fertile soil which means it's an
ideal place to grow cacao
the main ingredient in chocolate the
ancient maya grew it there 2500 years
ago
and people are still growing it there
today my name is victor alfredo diaz
cultivar cacao cola
fermenta
[Music]
a so
after the cacao is grown it's off to the
chocolatiers
brenda is a fourth generation
chocolatier she makes her chocolate the
same way her great-grandmother used to
back in the day
and now she's teaching her children to
do the same days
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is fernando he's a newer
chocolatier taking a more modern
approach to guatemala's chocolate
renaissance
[Music]
is
[Music]
traditional
[Music]
haven't you ever had those times in your
life where you just feel
all consumed with tasting something
again
that you haven't had in years and years
that's really what i'm
doing here is bringing back those
incredible desserts those incredible
experiences
that have gone extinct
i put myself through this process of
resurrecting desserts because i truly
feel
that a good dessert can change the
course of your day
i'm valerie gordon owner of valerie
confections
and i'm also a dessert anthropologist
the way this project of resurrecting
historic desserts began
was in 2009 the food editor from the los
angeles times magazine
asked me to create a plums coffee crunch
cake
for an article that she was doing and it
was this
amazing full circle moment because i
grew up with that cake
i know that cake and i missed that cake
terribly
blums was an incredible bakery and cafe
in california there were eight locations
the last one closed in the 80s
when the article came out we literally
received
125 phone calls from people going
oh my god i want this cake
so the desserts that i resurrected to
date are
of course the coffee crunch cake from
blums
i've brought back the banana shortcake
from chasen's
the brown derby grapefruit cake is
another cake that i've resurrected
and now is soon to be the coffiesta
sundae as well
the anthropology of the
dessert resurrection is really one of
the most
interesting parts of all of this i start
the research process
at the central library there is a room
and this is a
very well guarded room called the menu
vault
there are menus that date back for 150
years
i find that looking at the actual menus
is so much more gratifying than just
pulling something up online
because you're really getting to the
heart and soul of the place you're
almost transported
into that place at that time by holding
something that these people held
you really are then i email a bunch of
people or i call a bunch of people
who were natives to los angeles or
whatever city the bakery was in
to find out hey do you remember this do
you remember that we always used to call
this the adult sunday because this is
the one my mom would eat
can they describe the texture of a
whipped cream
can they tell me whether there was
vanilla in it or not i'm pretty sure
they did one basic yeah recipe for
whipped cream and then
flavored accordingly right it was little
kid whipped cream
one cherry yes this is amazing like you
you have been indispensable
i'm not particularly interested in retro
it is about
reliving those sense memories it's sort
of like when you hear a song
that was your favorite song from 1982
you're really thrown back into that
moment
it's become this very emotional
very fulfilling part of my job to bring
these cakes back for people
these little custard tarts these eggy
sugary treats are
everywhere in portugal here here and
here
some say the prestige de belang is the
original paste dinata
or custard tart in this little factory
through this kitchen
there's a recipe that has been kept top
secret for almost
200 oh not years one guys
i can't get in here i'm sorry
[Music]
okay i'm miguel clerini and i'm part of
the management of prestige blind
this special recipe you will only find
here at this shop
we sell an average of about twenty
thousand
tarts a day in the summer maybe around
forty thousand cakes
a lot of cakes the stages of belang as
they call them here
are simple tarts really egg yolk milk
some flour
sugar but it's how they make them in
complete secrecy
that makes these tarts a national
trigger
we have six people knowing the recipe
in the family my father my cousin
and myself miguel perino the three chefs
which is vitor
dominguez eliseo jamiro and
carlos martinez the recipe is so secret
all the bakers signed non-disclosure
agreements to keep the timeless tarts a
true mystery
[Music]
staged blind is one of the earliest
recipes at least here in lisbon
we know that the recipe was invented in
the monastery of geronimo
in the early 19th century this one
once they have the recipe the chefs now
sworn to secrecy
are giving keys to this door they work
inside the factory
in a separate room that we call the
ofcena do sugredo in portuguese it's
like the secret shop or secret room
they have to work in a separate room
because the process can only be seen
by them so today we haven't found anyone
that
explained the recipe as it is if it
happened well we
probably would have to lock him up in
the basement and throw away the key
no just kidding okay secret keeper
what's the best way to eat one of these
custard tarts
usually i like it simple but that's just
me most people like with a little bit of
cinnamon
on top this is the hard part of the job
[Music]
this is super hard i don't know how you
do it
you